we have a very special guest joining us
the number one overall pick in last NHL
draft Conor Bard with a big announcement
Connor it's good to have you
on yeah thank you um on on behalf of the
Chicago Blackhawks um you know we're
we're very excited to announce that
we'll be hosting the 2025 NHL Winter
Classic versus the uh St Louis Blues
here at Wrigley Field so uh we're all
pretty pumped first off you nailed that
uh and we appreciate it cuz we
originally we're going to have we're
going to have Biz do the announcement
and he was nervous he thought he was
going to butcher the entire thing so we
appreciate you being there and listen
it's so cool iconic setting you're the
top overall pick of the NHL draft the
future of the Blackhawks and we have a
Blackhawks Legend here in Chris chellos
who I know would like to talk to you
yeah and I know what a thrill it is we
got to play in one of those outdoor
games at Wrigley uh one one of those
years I was playing but uh yeah but uh
so the All-Star Game Connor I run into
your dad in the elevator and you're
running late for something and the first
place he was checking was a wait room
you might be the only player at an
All-Star event to go in the weight room
during the weekend but uh how was your
experience as first All-Star
game um it was great I mean obviously I
wish I was able to you know participate
and um you know play in the game but
obviously you know you some sometimes
that happens but um no it was awesome
just to be there with those guys and
take it in and I mean it was uh it was a
great seas in Toronto there that the
fans loved it and kind of took over the
city for the couple days so um it was
awesome to be part of Conor it's AER
just talk about your first allstar game
as a rookie of the National Hockey
League there's a ton of first first goal
first assist first city you playing on
the road first time you play against cdy
Crosby what's been your favorite first
so
far uh man that's pretty tough to pick
um you know I've been pretty fortunate
for a lot of a lot of special moments
but uh of course course the the first
first game we were able to win so uh
that was that was pretty exciting and uh
just that whole experience obviously
playing playing against Sid and and and
all those guys it was uh that was pretty
cool night Conor I ask you two my first
one's going to be I was talking to Gary
Roberts and he talked about how nervous
he was going to be playing with uh Wayne
Gretzky at his first All-Star game was
there anyone you were nervous just
meeting I know you weren't there playing
but you know being in the presence of
some of those greats that are in today's
game
um I mean I've been lucky to to meet a
lot of them I think the first time
meeting all of them I was pretty quiet
and didn't say too much but um now I got
to know uh a lot of those guys a little
bit so it's it's a little more
comfortable for sure and I mean in the
end we're all just people so um you know
you can have pretty normal conversations
but you know I remember the first time a
lot of those guys I was uh I was pretty
scared for sure and just my followup
wasn't it's not because of the broken
jaw but just how have you found the
adjustment from a physical perspective
stepping from Junior to the NHL at 18
years
old uh yeah for sure I mean you know
guys guys are big and uh big and strong
I think the biggest thing is just kind
of having your head up and um you know I
knew that coming in I'm not not a huge
guy or anything so if uh you know one of
the the big dmen kind of lines me up I
know it's not going to be good for me so
uh you know just kind of have my head up
and um you know being smart out there
and and kind of KN KN where to go so I
think you you learn that as as time goes
but um yeah I think it's it's all just
kind of instinct stuff I I want to
finish on this the on Ice adjustment is
one thing but you're a hockey player and
and you're a damn good one you are on
Wrigley Field you're on national TV
you're 18 years old and you are that
next athlete in Chicago that
recognizable face how is the adjustment
just to this life being so different for
you
Ben yeah I mean it's it's definitely uh
you know an adjustment I'd say you know
like you said hockey's hockey and and
obviously it's you know the hardest
league in the world and everything but
but you're always out there you know
trying to learn and get better and uh
but all fights it's it's definitely
different and obviously um you know just
getting used to that living on your own
and and all that stuff but uh it's been
a lot of fun and and I'll uh all my
teammates have been super helpful with
everything so um you know I'm pretty
fortunate to be in a city like this and
and with our fans and kind of the
support of of sports in general so um
yeah that that part's been been easy
well listen we can't wait to see you
back on the ice hopefully in two weeks
when we have you on the air that would
be nice uh but we also can't wait to see
you and the Blackhawks Wrigley field for
the Winter Classic uh so great Conor
Bard thanks so much for joining us
thanks
Conor